you guys look where I am right now yeah
first of all hi you guys may know
Marquez and give me HD and you're so
awesome and I can't believe that I'm
sitting here right now well thank you
just so exciting we're trying to figure
out what videos to do and I've been kind
of like asking people about what their
oldest piece of tech that they had and
you said you have your first Northover I
do so this when I first got actually too
smart not even my first phone this is
the first oldest phone I've ever had
nokia 3310 came out in 2000 first
smartphone I ever had was the Motorola
Droid but then we found something that
came out the same year that this did and
maybe a little more relevant to
Justine's channel I don't I don't I
don't even know are you sure are you
sure about this
totally confident that this will be an
interesting exciting unboxing I'm
already freaking out I think this is the
original tape this is the iBook so this
is the clamshell one and this was
shipped September 26 year 2000 so it's
an 18 year old piece of tech but still
unopened I don't know what happens when
you ship something like this does the
battery turret I don't know what happens
maybe it's gonna be perfectly fine this
tape has never been touched this is
great where did you get this this uh I
have a friend at red who used to work at
a company a long time ago had a bunch of
tech from there apparently had a room
with a bunch of these in it you said hey
do you want one I said yes here it is I
can't believe that you are you sure I
mean yes maybe the best part 300
megahertz PowerPC GT processor half a
megabyte of cache on that chip 64
megabytes of storage six gigabyte hard
disk
so Oh so 64 Meg's of RAM Wow about six
gigs of hard drive had a cd-rom drive do
you remember that I do I do
it wasn't even that long an optional
wireless airport card I wonder if this
has it optional Wi-Fi but it has a
built-in Ethernet Jess six hour battery
quick and easy internet access includes
30 day free internet access Microsoft
Internet Explorer Oh Outlook Express and
Netscape communicator do you remember
Netscape communicator
that's something I don't remember Oh Mac
OS pre-installed that's really
considerate that's good here we go I
don't know if I want it I do want to
i'll cut half of it then you cut the
other half okay we have a power strip in
case you want to plug it into that
feeling it's not still charged you'll
think it's a job my harness seals broken
I can't believe what's happening right
now yes this is this is monumental this
is 18 years oh it's upside down
I mean this box is in a really good
condition yes surprisingly not yellow so
this is a 2000 the whole thing comes up
I think I got my first G whoa wait is it
at an arena must be I'm so confused why
is there a box inside of the box oh no
it's not what's this assessories
probably the charger yes all that fun
stuff that's all right I should be
getting further this is crazy look at
this this doesn't really look like a
very Apple way to pop things show that
like this you're curious what stuff
shipped like oh don't drop it
that would be something I would do
that's okay we'll just
I never had one of these this remind you
of Mickey Mouse at all this looks
beautiful I have been researching
actually because I've wanted to get all
of the colors to find one of these that
has never been opened before how many
colors were there cuz I see tangerine
here there's tangerine blueberry yeah
graphite indigo and key lime the key
learning was the online exclusive this
is still sealed to your use of the
materials in closed media as subject to
terms presented for acceptance during
the installation of any printed blah
blah blah blah by opening this you agree
to all such printed terms we agree
where's the knife let's do it alright I
don't even get it like this is a weird
color it's just I feel like this just
doesn't look like a good design in 2018
it doesn't but I brought this back to
the year 2000 I think we might think
other wow that's the memo I think that's
not the power
there is no no oh it's a laptop no
that's right
this is the power this is what Apple's
sticky I am now thinking back to like
what it was like when these it's like I
mean the iMac really changed everything
IMAX is one of those machines that I
remember basically when I was in I think
it was like fifth grade where the
teacher had one in the back of the class
and if you were a good kid you got to
use it sometimes play some solitaire or
whatever you were into oh I didn't want
to rip it but I ripped it so how many
new people are out there they'd have
rooms of things that they don't have
opened a room of
yeah just this is a great color this
evening we were just talking about
colored gadgets and co-ed iPhones on the
other video this is nice
this isn't better-looking in person than
in the photo this is actually really
much better look we did an ask video on
your channel and we're talking about
iPhone colors and what's crazy is they
had all of these color choices and these
are computers they don't phones these
were extremely expensive device happen
you Apple these are nice you should
bring this back this is a different blue
than this oh and it has this when you
open it like new laptops when you open
them to have the little thing on the
screen
I'm almost I'm pumped to see the screen
because this is 18 year old display okay
I mean all of the ones that I've seen on
eBay like it's all discolored they have
a lot of cracking oh that's product that
is correct but it's got a handle it does
have a handle what a great idea this is
so early in the days of laptops that you
had to make sure people knew that they
could bring it places yeah so the first
laptops had these handles here are like
briefcase like almost and this is
probably closer to a purse type of thing
but bring it places if they brought the
handle back well now I got these sleeves
oh this leads true this is cracked see
that was a very common problem actually
easy there's a lot of really interesting
aesthetic things about this computer the
keys you can sort of see through the
keyboard to see the switches it's an
elbow keyboard for sure yeah nice
every key is concave and then I was
looking for speakers I don't think
there's any up here it's just this
single circle all the ports there's a
headphone some ports never die that's
true except apparently until 2018
but you got to have fun with it dying
yeah at first I was kind of mad but I
got my first phone with no headphone
and I was just kind of forced into being
okay with it so I have wireless
headphones now I'm okay
we're okay it'll be all right but this
is back in the glory days and then oh
man
over here we're looking at you have your
modem you ever Ethernet and then you
have one single full-size USB port one
like what are you supposed to do with
that plug in your mouse
technically today's laptops are
throwback that's true and then this is
your speaker output so you have a
headphone jack on once we know that's
the power oh I thought that folks that's
easy that's the headphone jack
there's no mic input that's the power
cable what is this I actually really
like this yeah he wasn't aware that
that's how the power cable worked it's
actually a really cool idea I guess so
apples always had a sort of a smart idea
as far as power cables MagSafe was one
of my favorites ever I really miss it
all right I'm reckless
oh and it's just plugs into the top
trying to boot it before plugging in
there's no way I mean if this has
battery then I break it and it just goes
really really far back well plugged in
you Justine are pressing the power
button looks like an air pod
it's no MagSafe but it lit up a little
green glowing circle I think that means
it's time to press the button I don't
you I don't know about you but I'm ready
okay hard drives this
mac os9 holy moly you can see in its
Bryton everything oh oh my god oh and
also feel the this the click eNOS is
kind of cuz I went like this like
expecting it to click is not the worst
touch trackpad obviously oh my gosh all
the plugins the control panel holy crap
I'm losing my freaking mind
it doesn't seem to have any problems at
all
no just me turn it off no no in dark the
mouse is still here I think it's playing
like a little like the the intro welcome
to your computer for the first time ever
oh wow get hyped I just wanna see you
freak out one day what is going on about
something oh this is the first boot like
welcome Cassie the continue button this
is kind of way I'm getting like such a
throwback because I was going into
college when these sort of started
coming out and I went to school for
graphic design so a lot of my design I
was like mimicking from this like
interface this is not I'm gonna quit
okay if there is this register you
register your product can I skip that
who's it gonna send this information to
whatever else I mean novel has my entire
life I can see from here literally every
single pixel but that's fine
where will you primarily use this
computer at school college or government
government and then what describes you
best design publishing yeah sure yes me
all about that graphite one in the
middle
it looks good I'm all about it you had
your email in there so you just sent a
registration here I've look Cisco oh
it's not gonna connected to the Internet
oh that's true do you want to get on the
Internet
yes I wonder for Internet trial I'll use
my existing internet tell me more about
the Internet the Internet is a worldwide
network of computers that you can access
using your computer and a telephone line
it's simple to continue about the
Internet
yeah it's just people who are on the
internet they
talk to you can you imagine being what
have we stopped with the iconic some
more about the internet this is probably
a lot of people's first machine that
ever connected to the Internet yeah
considering how long this tutorial is
when you want to browse the web or send
and receive email your computer dials
your ISP and it connects to the internet
usually it's a local phone call so write
in the comments below let me know how
old you guys were in 2000 you're gonna
be mad at how many people say they
weren't born yet I know it's actually
shocking yeah I've had a Mac my entire
life from the beginning like our first
one that we had it was like the original
Mac it was the one megabyte version the
Power Mac g4 was my first computer
that's what I took my senior picture
with I instead of buying a car when I
turned 16 I spent all of my money on
this classroom I had had this color IMAX
this is a long tutorial yeah Wow
they really don't want us messing around
world book is World Book Encyclopedia
yeah I used to just read it because I
had nothing else on my computer except
the world book trial oh now we're in an
email tutorial this is intense
oh he's an exit button should I just
exit I think we're gonna get the point
yeah area network yeah I used to go to
land parties because we didn't have
internet like we did not have internet
that we could actually play games with
each other so we need to bring our
computers to each others house something
that sit next to each other and maybe
chosen Mountain Dew and a pizza and it
was it was a time to be alive or the
shirt for a reason the the Apple logo up
in the corner is your classic Apple
rainbow logo I'm gonna have to do some
research and insert some fun facts for
you guys here okay the launcher down
here I completely forgot about that yeah
that is pretty intense I keep wanting to
for such oh wow tinnie gosh do you
invert ICQ my time I didn't even have
the oil Instant Messenger I still
remember my ICQ number let's try it this
thing's gonna turn to a 2018 MacBook Pro
I plug it into the suspense
I'm figuring your system this will only
take a moment I feel like a moment back
in 2000 was a lot longer than you're
going online it says okay if you have
questions or get stuck you can always
refer to these twirls and how about you
click connect connect explore look at
this uh security film you try a
different website I think my first
website that I ever went to is
nintendo.com oh my gosh something's
happening online kinda it's loading well
because this is such an old browser that
there's no way that this is really
really supported well google or is this
just like a cached version because
[Music]
that's working it's working that's
working do we try to watch a youtube
video there's no way it's gonna work I
mean what also gonna do I don't know oh
my gosh Netscape communicator this was
an upgrade from navigator look at the
forth quit oh my gosh do you guys
remember this probably not because some
of you were born yet you I remember this
it works so keycaps I have a very fond
memory so this was a keyboard that my
mom wouldn't she would ground me if I
didn't get at least A's or B's and if I
got a C she would take my computer away
for nine weeks until the next report
card she used to take the keyboard and
the mouse but I had an extra mouse so
what I would do is I meet my computer up
when she was gone and I would use key
caps to chat with my friends cuz I would
just chat on he caps coffee she's not
watching this but that's actually
brilliant she knows I told her like many
years later and she caught me so then
she got smart and then just like had to
put a lock on him I'm the actual desk
that the computer is in no printer
attached to you right unfortunate all
your application
oh boy it's gonna take forever to search
oh yeah hard drive oh my got a senior
officer you put in world look yeah there
it is OCD drab pops right out yeah and
then get this sound probably whoa it's
happening
that's so Wow this Dodger oh wow look at
this oh my gosh I remember these things
Jesus this is crazy
all these transparent elements you can
see through the CD don't want to shake
it up too much with the CD uh-huh but on
this cruise all the spears and stuff you
get the vent up top
oh did install and then no webcam at the
top just as I booked ideas maybe Oh
deletion was successful that's a good
sound okay
let's open it up and learn now this is
still gonna be the world look from mm
what's learn about bees well what is
happening right now
I thought the CD sound with this no the
sound that plays when you look for bees
that's awesome that's that's pretty good
really insane what other animal sounds
would a play if I looked up that animal
course right now is it gonna nag me baby
oh wow
well I know what you're gonna do in your
free time now things make wait this is
the test what does the Fox say
there's no sound at the top not even
worldbook mm knows what the Fox is I
mean we were still asking ourselves what
the Fox said in what year was that that
was 2000 there are 13 Tina
we didn't know in 2000 and we still
don't know today I don't even know what
else we can do with this I mean we got
on the Internet
you're now registered for a 2008 I want
to get an email at some point of like
thank you for registering for Netscape
communicator welcome to the Internet I'm
still it I'm really happy that it worked
right away this is plugged in in case
you missed it straight to our router
here in the studio so it's definitely
pumping way more than this was expecting
well thank you so much because this was
such a special throwback moment like
this I didn't cry so that's good I did
make it through this whole video but I
probably will cry when I'm editing it
but this was so awesome the logo on the
back is upside down
I flipped it over yes I was like a huge
thing with it when you're out in the
coffee shop people would know you have a
Mac because I wanna be right side up
make sure you guys go check out the
video we did in his channel I'll put a
link in the description and be sure to
subscribe and go check out a channel if
you have it already which I'm sure many
of you have this was so awesome thank
you so much I'm super happy to be a part
of it
thanks for having me thank you okay bye
guys
[Music]